[Captions by Y Translator]
What's going to happen to milk
when you take all
of the water out of it?
How about chocolate milk?
What's it going to turn into?
[Music]
Not too long ago,
we had a video where we
dehydrated two bottles of soda,
and the result I thought
was really interesting.
What we ended up
with was this super
thick concentrated syrup
that looked really cool.
We have a Coke one,
and an Orange one,
and they both ended up like
a liquid gelatin sort of stuff.
I really like that result,
and I wanted to try it
with some other stuff.
So today, we're going
to see what happens
if we dehydrate milk.
We've got the Dehydro-Tron 5000,
and we've got our trays.
So we're going
to put some milk in.
But along with that,
we're also going to try
some chocolate milk,
and I thought
that there would be
a few different ways to do that.
Maybe we can get
some pre-made chocolate milk,
but it's harder to tell
if that's really going
to turn into a powder,
and that's what
I'm hoping will get is
that both of these will
dehydrate down into something
that can then be turned
into a complete powder.
And I figure
if we use something
that starts as a powder,
we know that it's not going
to turn into any sort of liquid
as it dehydrates.
To start off,
we're going to take
one of our trays,
put in our dehydrator,
and add about two
and a half cups,
or 20 ounces of milk,
and then we're going to mix up
the same amount of milk
with some chocolate powder,
and add that onto another tray.
[Music]
Now, what we need to do is wait.
Dehydrating is not
a super fast process,
and milk has a lot
of liquid in it.
So this is gonna take
a little bit of time.
I would guess at least a couple
of days before this is really
dehydrated all the way,
and as usual,
I'll be monitoring it,
and if the trays seem like
they're evaporating unevenly,
I might switch
their places in there,
turn the heat up and down
as is necessary.
But we're going
to just let this run
until that milk is
completely devoid of liquid.
So while we wait,
I want to take a second
to talk about Audible,
the sponsor for today's video.
Audible has the largest
selection of audio books,
and they're always
adding new content,
so they keep things fresh.
Something new that
they've just released
is called Audible Originals.
Audible Originals are
exclusive audio titles created
by celebrated storytellers
from things like theater,
literature, journalism,
and more.
Since these audible
original pieces are made
for and exclusive to Audible,
you can't get them else.
Audible is offering new
listeners a free 30-day trial
that comes with one credit good
for an audiobook,
and two credits good
for Audible Originals.
With Audible,
all of your media is
yours to keep, even
if you cancel your membership.
You can go back at any time
and listen to pieces,
even if you aren't
currently a subscriber.
Recently, I've been listening
to the audio book called
Legion: The Many Lives of Steven Leads
by Brandon Sanderson.
It's great because
I love reading,
but I don't often like
to sit still long enough
to read a hardcopy.
Get one free audiobook,
and two Audible Originals
when you try Audible
for free for 30 days.
Go to audible.com/thekingofrandom,
or text "thekingofrandom" to 500500.
That's audible.com/t-h-e-k-i-n-g-o-f-r-a-n-d-o-m.
It's now been a couple of days,
and our milk
is completely dehydrated.
Remember, we had
normal milk and we had
some chocolate milk mixed in
with a chocolate powder.
So now we're going to reveal
what we've got inside,
what it looks like,
how dry is it,
what texture is it,
can we blend it up
into a powder,
can we rehydrate it?
Let's check this out.
[Music]
There is our standard milk.
Here's our chocolate milk.
So right off the bat,
a couple of observations.
One, the standard milk seems
to be cracking a lot more,
and it didn't really break up
like that on its own.
Most of that's from
when I would switch
the sheets back and forth,
so they had equal exposure time
directly above the light bulb,
and being on top
where it wasn't quite
so direct to heat.
And I'm sure my fingers
just kind of popped it,
because it's very thin aluminum,
very easy to bend.
So I do think
that probably broke
it up a little bit.
But you can really see
like this is dry.
This just flakes
apart immediately.
Even the thicker
sections over here,
just completely crumbly.
Look at the chocolate.
So we do have
some crumbliness, definitely.
Bits her breaking off.
It's not quite as weak
as the plain milk.
Oh, and then parts,
it's even still fairly flexible.
Something in the chocolate
powder seems to be preventing it
from getting quite as crinkly,
at least everywhere.
Some of the chocolate seems
to have settled out of the milk,
and one side is
this light color,
and the other side,
that's just very much
a the color of chocolate.
Kind of some fun popped bubble
textured all over this.
Now, I know
you're expecting this,
and yes, I am going to taste it,
and see what it's like.
So, here goes.
This is just a flake
of completely dehydrated milk.
[Music]
It's kind of gross.
I think it even does sort
of have a milk flavor,
but a milk flavor
should only be in milk.
On something else
that has that sort
of texture in your mouth,
really not pleasant.
I don't recommend that.
Dehydrated chocolate milk.
Let's try a piece of this.
[Music]
Hmm.
Well, the chocolate flavor
does come through,
but less than I thought.
[Music]
That milky taste is
still very present.
Yeah, the texture
on this definitely is
a little bit gummier.
It's not like a gummy,
but it has a little bit
more chew to it.
Whereas the plain
milk just crunched
and crumbled apart in my mouth,
and when I was chewing on it,
this stuff has a little
bit of resistance.
It's not going to
catch on as a candy.
[Music]
This does a great job
of not sticking to our tray.
If you saw our
dehydrating slime video,
that was a lot harder to get
off of our aluminum tray.
The milk though is just kind
of popping right off.
It's really nice.
We've got two and
a half cups of milk,
that's about 20 ounces
of liquid in this right here.
And in this one,
we have what's left
after we dehydrated it.
So I want to see
the weight difference.
How much have we lost?
Start with ounces.
Now, including our
measuring cup here,
we are at 43.63 ounces.
[Music]
25.33.
If my math is right,
we have lost 18.3 ounces,
or 718 grams by dehydrating our milk.
So now of course,
what we need to do is to see
if we can rehydrate this.
I think it's going to work best
if we try and turn
this into a powder,
and then mix it in with water.
We'll measure out
the same amount of water
that we lost,
then we'll try
mixing it back in.
See if it works.
[Music]
That is mostly turned into dust.
Looks like I do still
have some bigger pieces.
These pieces that were softer.
I'm gonna try
and take those out,
and run them through again.
[Music]
We're just going
to stick with grams,
all of our International friends
will thank us for using
the metric system for once here.
The weight of my cup
with the dehydrated milk in it
was zeroed out on the scale,
and then I put the cup with
the non dehydrated milk in it,
and I get 521 grams.
So that should be
what I need to add in water to
get to the total weight again.
[Music]
There we go.
521.
This is looking super gross.
It's also not mixing well,
so you know what?
I think we're going
back in the blender.
We're going to try
and blend it all together.
[Music]
That looks like milk.
It looks like milk
that's got something
kind of weird going on,
and there's clearly
some solids still down
in that did not blend well.
But I think the real test
here is obvious.
[Music]
That is not good.
So this isn't any good
in my personal opinion.
But it does taste
like dehydrated milk,
just the product that you
can buy at the store.
I have had times in my life
where I drank dehydrated
milk for a while,
and while I definitely
didn't like it,
it's better than no milk at all.
And this tastes quite a bit
in the same to me.
Think our next test
needs to be to see
if we can do this
with the chocolate milk.
Well that restore back
to being chocolate milk?
Will it be any good?
And I'm also going to do a test
where I try heating
up the water to see
if that helps blend
it back in better,
and to see if it
will make hot chocolate.
We need another
521 grams of water,
and then we're going to mix
that in with our
chocolate dehydrated milk.
We're gonna use hot water
to see it dissolves a little bit better.
[Music]
Ow. My poor thumb.
Whoa! Foams up a fair bit,
so it no longer fits
of that container.
I'm afraid this is too hot,
so I'm using spoon.
That is worse
than the regular milk.
The chocolate taste is just
really not there the same way
I thought it would be.
I'd--
It was pretty rich
when I made it.
It doesn't taste
like hot chocolate.
I mean, it's...
You can kind of say like,
oh that's hot,
and I guess
a little bit chocolatey?
But I wouldn't call
it hot chocolate.
I don't like that.
And I suppose it's also possible
that it picked up
some of the taste
of the aluminum tray
that was sitting on,
because it does almost have
metallicky sort of taste.
Yeah, I'm gonna go
with not a fan.
Just want to make sure I
actually got the liquid
and not just the foam.
[Music]
Yeah, still not good.
Like it's not like it
tastes like poison.
You're just like, I--
Why would I--
I wouldn't drink that on purpose.
It's not enjoyable.
Can you dehydrate milk entirely
in our dehydrator?
Yes, you can.
It actually worked pretty well,
went decently fast,
and just turned
into this flaky crumbly mess.
I was able to powderized
that in the blender.
It powderized pretty well,
turned into this very fine dust,
and it even kind of rehydrated.
It tastes pretty similar
to commercially available
dehydrated milk.
I did some research,
and I thought it was interesting
how they usually go
about making that.
They'll take the normal milk.
They'll put it in an evaporator,
something that's slightly heated
to get rid of some of the excess water.
While they're heating up,
they'll actually also put it
in a partial vacuum.
The lower pressure makes it
so that the water will boil off
at a lower temperature,
about a 135 degrees Fahrenheit.
After about 1/3 of the liquid
has been boiled off at low pressure,
they'll then take
the concentrated milk,
and they'll spray
it into a chamber
that's heated up.
Heated so high that the water
actually evaporates out
of it almost instantaneously,
so you have these tiny little
sprayed particles going in,
and then drying out right away.
So just the act of spraying it
like that sort of turns it into
a powder already dehydrated.
They don't need
to dehydrate it on a sheet,
scrape it off,
and then blend it
up the way I was doing here.
They just spray concentrated
milk into a heated chamber,
and it turns into
dehydrated milk powder.
Thanks again to Audible
for sponsoring today's video.
Check the link
in the description,
or go to
audible.com/thekingofrandom
to start your free trial,
and get one free audiobook,
and two free Audible Originals.
Guys, that's it for today,
but the fun doesn't
have to end here.
That box up at the top will take
you directly to our last video.
You should go check that out.
The other box will show you
what YouTube thinks you
should do watching next,
and if you aren't subscribed
to the channel yet,
hit this bomb to get
in the club.
That way you never miss
out on the fun.
Don't forget to ring that bell,
and we'll see you
in the next one.
Talk to you then.